The strategy we've been using to solve these problems is definitely useful, but
there are different interest options for Grant to explore. What if instead of
only compounding the interest once a year, his account compounded it twice a
year? Now, interest rate is still quoted as a yearly rate. So let's say he
keeps it at 3%. However, since his interest is going to be compounded twice a
year or semi-annually, then each time the compounding happens, the rate that's
used is only going to be half of this annual rate. That means that each time we
do a calculation, we're not going to use the number 0.03 anymore, instead,
we're going to use half of that. I'd like you to help me describe the situation
by filling in some numbers for me in a few sentences. Here's what I'd like you
to tell me. If Grant invests $10,000 at a 3% annual rate compounded twice a
year, then in six months, he will receive 1.5% on his $10,000 investment. Which
means that some amount of money, which you'll write in here, will be added to
his account in interest. The total balance of the account will then be whatever
you think. Then after six more months, Grant will again receive 1.5% interest,
but this time, on the new amount. The interest added this time is going to be
something, which will make the total amount of money in the account after one
year equal to what?